scp 682 versus a vacuum and we're not  talking about the household cleaning  appliance could the hard to destroy  reptile survive in a completely air-free  environment to find out 99 of the oxygen  was removed from a testing chamber that  scp-682 was trapped inside the creature  entered a dormant state and began  producing what the foundation believed  to be its native atmosphere a mixture of  56 ozone 23 chlorine 18 xenon and other  caustic elements the test was eventually  called to an end however when our normal  earth atmosphere was reintroduced into  the room it reacted with the compound  that 682 was releasing and caused a  massive explosion that blew off the  blast door a scientist remarked that it  was no wonder 682 was so hardy if that  poisonous mix was its native atmosphere